en el vídeo anterior resolvimos este
problema 65 y obtuvimos la respuesta de
manera intuitiva pero hay otra forma de
resolverlo que nos hubiera servido si
nos hubiera tocado un problema un poco
más complicado y esto es el teorema de
binomios y también coeficientes binomial
es y podremos ver cómo se relacionan
mutuamente y me di cuenta de que debo
hacer esto porque en los siguientes
problemas tienen que ver con
coeficientes de binomios así que lo
resolveré usando esto que seguramente es
lo que piden en este examen es bueno
saber resolver esto de varias maneras
para comprender cómo son todo lo mismo
buena y mariana son dos estudiantes que
están entre diez estudiantes que han
aplicado para un viaje a washington dc
dos estudiantes del grupo serán elegidos
aleatoriamente para el viaje cuál es la
probabilidad de que wendy y mediana sean
a los estudiantes seleccionadas en la
ocasión anterior lo resolvimos
intuitivamente dimos cuenta de la
probabilidad de que escogieran a wendy y
después de marianna y nos sumamos con el
caso contrario por lo que sería 2
1 entre 10 por 1 entre más
2 porque hay dos maneras de seleccionar
a las estudiantes y para cada una de
esas maneras hay una probabilidad entre
10 para que eligen a la primera persona
y una probabilidad entre 9 para que
elijan a la segunda esa fue la forma
intuitiva en que lo resolvimos en el
vídeo anterior
la manera de hacerlo usando coeficientes
binomial es es decir
tengo diez elementos 10 estudiantes en
este caso así que aquí pongo mis 10
elementos y de estos días voy a elegir 2
la gente lee esto como de 10 elegir 2 o
de 10 seleccionar 2 y eso es útil de
memorizar hasta cierto punto esto
significa esto es igual a tener 10
factorial entre 2 factorial 2
factoriales por 10 menos 2 factorial
es igual a 10 factorial entre 2
factoriales 10 menos 238 factorial
ustedes pueden pensar más allá 10
factorial pues es un número enorme me
tomará mucho tiempo calcularlo pero
deben darse cuenta de que lo dividen
entre 8 factorial esto de 10 factorial
es lo mismo que tener 10 por 9 por 8 por
7 así es sucesivamente hasta 1
y este 8 es lo mismo que tener 8 por 7
por 6 etc entonces a partir de aquí de
este 8 esto es lo mismo que lo que tengo
aquí abajo así que se cancelan por lo
que me queda aquí arriba 10 por 9 90
entre factorial de 22 por 12 que da 2 90
entre 2 esto es igual a 45
así que la probabilidad de que esto
ocurra es 1 entre 45 así que tenemos la
misma respuesta que en el vídeo anterior
la intuición detrás de esto es que hay
10 maneras para seleccionar al primer
estudiante y 9 maneras de seleccionar el
segundo estudiante y también tenemos dos
formas de elegir a una persona y luego a
la otra es la misma intuición de cómo lo
resolvimos en la vez anterior ahora
veamos el siguiente problema el
siguiente problema es esto
número 66 3 x menos 1 a la cuarta esto
podemos multiplicarlo usando
multiplicaciones algebraicas regulares
aunque nos llevaría bastante tiempo pero
yo me imagino que aquí lo que quieren es
que usemos el teorema binomial y la
extensión binomial de esto voy a usar la
anotación de coeficientes binomial es y
creo que ustedes notarán el patrón ya
hay vídeos previos donde se explica esto
con más detalle entonces esto de aquí va
a ser igual a nuestra población de 4 que
seleccionamos 0
x el primer término elevado a la cuarta
potencia este es mi primer término así
que lo multiplicó esto 3 a la cuarta
potencia
multiplicando los pobres segundo término
a la potencia a cero que es uno y pues
no lo voy a escribir entonces pongo más
ahora los coeficientes de 4 selecciono 1
x el primer elemento elevado al cubo
es que al cubo
y estoy de crem en tanto la potencia en
cada término esto lo voy a multiplicar
por el segundo término elevado a la
primera potencia que el primer término
es menos uno elevado a la primera
potencia que da igual y en general
cuando ustedes quieran saber cuál es la
potencia de este último elemento va a
ser la misma que el número que tengamos
aquí abajo este de acá en el anterior
este número fue cero y quedó como un y
no le escribe quizás ustedes puedan
adivinar cómo va a continuar esto cómo
van a ser los siguientes términos aquí
voy a tener más de cuatro seleccionados
por tres y al cuadrado
al cuadrado por menos 1 al cuadrado más
de 4 seleccionó 3
3 a la 1 x menos 1 al cubo más y lo
escribo aquí abajo
más
de 4 seleccionó 4 x
pero de igual a igual
este es uno lo hubiera omitido pero
bueno
al menos uno a la cuarta y ahora vamos a
sustituir este de cuatro seleccionó cero
esto es lo mismo que tener cuatro
factorial entre cero factorial por 4 - 0
factorial por cierto el factorial de
cero es 1
así que nos quedan 4 factorial entre 4
factorial que esto es igual a 1 así que
estoy aquí es 1
este tres a la cuarta tres por 3 9 por 3
27 por 3 81 así que nos quedan
voy a escribirlo aquí abajo este término
de acá 81 y a la cuarta el siguiente
término es aquí tenemos menos 1 todo
esto va a ser negativo menos de 4
selecciono uno luego escribiré cada
cuatro seleccionados domingo que 4
factorial entre 1 factorial por 4 - 1
factorial
que es igual a 4 factorial 4 - 13
y esto nos va a dar 4 hagan ustedes la
operación para que vean que es verdad
así que este término es esto es 4
tenemos que es menos 4 por este menos 13
y al cubo 3 al cubo es 27 así que esto
es 27 y al cubo
el siguiente término más porque es menos
1 al cuadrado va a ser 1 este se
mantiene positivo más de 4 seleccionados
cuatro factorial entre 2 factorial por 4
menos dos factorial
esto va a ser 2 factorial y esto me va a
quedar que es igual a 4 por 3 por 2 por
1 y esto es 2
este 4 de acá se va con estos dos y esto
me queda 3 por 2 por 1 es igual a 6 así
que quien queda 6 3 y al cuadrado 3 por
39 al cuadrado este menos 1 al cubo es
menos 1 aquí pasa el término negativo de
4 seleccionó 3 éste se los voy a dejar
de tarea pero yo sé que una vez que ya
pasamos la mitad del coeficiente viene
miel va a ser igual a 4 así que va a ser
menos 4 por 3
y el último término de 4 seleccionó 4
resulta que va a ser 1 como tengo este
menos 1 a la cuarta va a ser 1 así que
tengo al final más 1
este es un 3 vamos a simplificar esto
esto de aquí esto de aquí me sigue
quedando 81 y a la cuarta
- 4 x 27 va a ser igual a 108-108 y al
cubo 6 por 954 ye cuadrada 54 y cuadrada
menos 3 por 4 12 y azul
este es el desarrollo usando
coeficientes binomial es de esto y
resulta que es la opción a otra forma de
resolver esto en lugar de estar
resolviendo cada uno de los coeficientes
binomial es es usando el triángulo de
pascal si yo tengo de hecho voy a hacer
un poco de espacio para explicar el
templo de pascal si yo tengo este
binomio además ve a la 1 los
coeficientes nos van a ser 1 y 1 si yo
tengo a más b al cuadrado los
coeficientes van a ser
los coeficientes van a ser 1 1 1 2
y aquí 1 y tiene sentido porque además b
al cuadrado es igual a 1 a cuadrada más
2 por ave +1 por b al cuadrado y así
podemos continuar si tenemos además b al
cubo
los coeficientes serán
12 son 32 las 13 aquí queda 1 y para la
cuarta potencia como en este problema
nuestros coeficientes van a ser para a
más b
a la cuarta los coeficientes van a ser
la pirámide ok va a ser 11 343 más 363
más 14 y aquí uno en este caso teníamos
es menos 1 a la cuarta
si yo sustituyó esto aquí con estos
coeficientes si a resulta ser a estrés
y ve es igual a menos 1 si yo sustituyó
esto con esto nos va a quedar uno por
tres y a la cuarta
+ 4 x 3 al cubo por menos uno a la uno
más
por 3 al cuadrado por menos 1 al
cuadrado más 4
por 3 y 1 como ven estoy de crem en
tanto el exponente del primer término y
aumentando el exponente del segundo
término en cada iteración de esto x
menos 1 al cubo más 1 por 30 x menos 1 a
la cuarta y sólo nos faltaría evaluar
todo esto para encontrar que tenemos el
mismo resultado que en el método
anterior y quizás este método hubiera
sido más rápido de resolver pero quería
que vieran diferentes formas de resolver
esto resolvimos pocos problemas en este
vídeo pero creo que valió la pena